quel bilan pour parcoursup demande du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
je vous rappelle que dans le cadre de ce
débat le gouvernement aura la faculté si
le juge nécessaire de prendre la parole
immédiatement après chaque orateur où
auratrice pour une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposera alors à son tour
d'endroit de répartis pour une minute
madame la ministre vous pourrez donc si
vous le souhaitez répondre après chaque
orateur à votre choix vous signalerez
une fois que celui-ci aura retrouvé une
place dans l'hémicycle
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
Monsieur Pierre Ouzoulias pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
monsieur le Président Madame Lamisse mes
chers collègues nous avons proposé ce
débat non seulement pour dresser un
bilan des conséquences de la procédure
nationale de pré-inscription et
d'orientation des candidats dénommés
parcoursup mais aussi pour échanger sur
l'université et encore plus généralement
sur les missions du service public de
l'enseignement supérieur nos sociétés
par leur système productif reste
grandement dépendantes des matières
fossiles le charbon le pétrole et le gaz
sur lesquels elles ont bâti leur essor à
la fin du XVIIIe siècle nul ne conteste
plus que les rejets massifs de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère ont
provoqué un réchauffement climatique qui
menace aujourd'hui notre existence même
il a fallu près de trois siècles pour
développer une économie exploitant à
l'extrême les capacités des énergies
fossiles il ne nous reste plus que
quelques décennies pour les abandonner
et refonder l'essentiel de nos
productions sur votre ressources jamais
depuis l'aube de l'humanité nos sociétés
n'ont été confrontées à des dossiers
aussi considérables soyons persuadés que
seul le savoir la recherche et la
mobilisation de toutes les intelligences
nous permettront de surmonter ces
épreuves l'université parce qu'elle
forme les esprits dont nous aurons
besoin et parce qu'elles participent
directement à ce grand effort de
surcroît de connaissance devrait être au
cœur de nos politiques et un des objets
essentiels de nos priorités publiques or
les moyens que l'État lui consacre ne
cesse de baisser proportionnellement au
nombre d'étudiants qu'elle accueille bon
nombre d'établissements sont au bord de
la banqueroute et ne savent pas
aujourd'hui comment il se chauffer cet
hiver comment expliquer ce paradoxe
comment comprendre cette contradiction
entre nous énormes besoins en matière de
formation et de recherche et la pauvreté
des moyens de l'université quelle est la
cause de ce mal français il procède
principalement à mon avis du fait que
les élites françaises
ignorent l'université et parfois la
méprise elle considère de façon générale
qui n'est point besoin de trop investir
dans l'université tant que les grandes
écoles continueront d'assurer leur
reproduction
cette dichotomie entre des grandes
écoles bien dotées et des universités
nécessiteuses est anciennes il trouve
sans doute son origine dans les réformes
napoléoniennes rappelons que l'État
octroie aujourd'hui 4 fois plus de
financement un élève de classe
préparatoire qu'un étudiant de licence
il n'est pas possible de dresser un
bilan de l'orientation et de parcoursup
sans souligner les disproportions de
moyens accordés à ces deux systèmes au
sein même du service public par le passé
à plusieurs reprises des gouvernements
tentèrent de réduire cette fracture
l'intégration des classes préparatoires
au sein des universités fut ainsi l'une
des mesures proposées par Edgar Faure
dans son projet de réforme de
l'université une réaction corporatiste
relayée par des ministres importants de
son gouvernement eux-mêmes issus des
grandes écoles l'obligea à y renoncer
dans ces mémoires le général de commenta
ainsi cet échec je le cite ayant
moi-même élargi à l'extrême
l'enseignement public je tiens donc à y
faire s'instaurer depuis le bas jusqu'en
haut l'orientation et la sélection il me
fut une fois de plus démontré qu'un
moins de faire table rase par la
dictature ou par la Révolution aucune
institution ne peut vraiment être
réformée si ces membres n'y consent pas
je cite à des saints de général de
Gaulle car c'est sous son gouvernement
que le processus de démocratisation de
l'université a connu son évolution la
plus radicale en 1900 entre 1958 et 1968
le nombre de bacheliers généraux fut
multipliés par trois comme les effectifs
d'étudiants qui passèrent de 170 000 à
500 000 et celui des ingénieurs qui
doubla je rappelle que le CNRS comptait
6000 agents en 1958 et 16000 en 1968
cette accroissement sans équivalent fut
pensé et organiser pour accompagner des
investissements massifs dans tous les
domaines de la science et de la
technologie il fallait des cerveaux pour
les programmes très ambitieux consacrés
notamment aux industries nucléaires et
spatiales Maurice Duverger a résumé
cette politique par cette formule dans
les sociétés industrielles le
malthusianisme universitaire est une
absurdité
alors que nous sommes présentement
confrontés à des objectifs
technologiques bien plus considérables
cet exemple d'une planification réussie
qui lit l'augmentation de l'offre de
formation à la croissance des moyens de
la recherche doit être pris pour exemple
il a un conséquent de vouloir porter
l'effort de recherche et développement
de la France à 3% de son pays B sans
investir massivement dans ces
universités la difficulté je le conçois
et d'organiser cet effort de formation
pour qu'il participe au développement de
nos capacités de recherche tout en
préservant la nécessaire autonomie
pédagogique des universités et sans à
moindre rire les ressources d'une
recherche fondamentale dont les apports
ne seront effectifs que dans plusieurs
décennies cette équation très difficile
à résoudre oblige préalablement l'État à
réfléchir à une programmation à la
discuter avec les scientifiques et à
faire une fine des choix politiques
autant de perspectives régulièrement
ignoré par la malnomée loi de
programmation de la recherche pour être
plus concret j'aimerais prendre
l'exemple de la formation des médecins
pour réduire les dépenses de santé il a
été décidé il y a plusieurs dizaines
d'années de diminuer le nombre de
médecins formés la réussite de cette
politique est-elle qu'il faut maintenant
renverser la logique pour réduire la
carence de médecins si chaque université
organise en totale autonomie sont
recrutement il est douteux que la somme
des choix de ces établissements face une
politique nationale dans son rapport sur
la mise en oeuvre de réforme de santé
notre collègue la sénatrice Sonia de la
pauvreté a proposé que le recrutement
des étudiants en médecine obéissent à
des objectifs infra régionaux définis
nationalement pour tenter de mieux
satisfaire les besoins des territoires
la logique qui sous-tend la procédure
dite de parcoursup et radicalement
inverse sa seule finalité est de donner
aux établissements les moyens techniques
d'ajuster leur recrutement à leurs
moyens budgétaires
parcoursup leur permet de gérer la
pénurie en conformant les demandes
au moyen parcoursup et le lit de
Procuste de l'enseignement supérieur
les termes du débat que nous vous
proposons dépasse donc la comparaison
comptable des mérites respectives d'APB
et de parcoursup ou la simple
revendication de l'abrogation de cette
dernière procédure si nous défendons
encore le principe d'une université
républicaine au service de la nation
apprenante si nous voulons toujours
rendre la raison populaire comme le
souhaitait Condorcet si nous estimons de
même que l'université peut être un outil
efficace de l'aménagement du territoire
et de la satisfaction d'objectifs
scientifiques à long terme alors il
convient de réfléchir ardemment aux
conditions d'un dialogue renouvelé entre
l'État garant d'une planification
ambitieuse et les universités qui la
mettent en œuvre dans le respect de de
l'autonomie des équipes pédagogiques je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur ouzulias Madame la
Ministre allez-y
[Musique]
méritographie mais à l'aube du 21e
siècle oui nous avons toujours les mêmes
missions cœur de nos établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs et de
recherche mais inscrite dans notre
époque notre société et tous les défis
que vous avez cités que nous avons à
relever aujourd'hui et demain c'est
pourquoi avec conviction et en toute
responsabilité nous allons effectivement
mettre en place ce dialogue renouvelé
avec les universités mais aussi avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'ESR alors au
niveau de parcoursup rapidement il faut
rappeler au moment de se débat que la
procédure parcoursup assure un échange
entre les lycéens et les enseignants des
formations post-bac que la loi du 8
décembre 2018 a effectivement organisé
ce débat qui nous réunit ce soir et
l'occasion je n'en doute vraiment pas de
revenir sur le chemin parcouru depuis 5
ans au service de plus millions d'usagés
qui ont utilisé parcoursup depuis 2018
et de discuter des axes qui nous
permettront de continuer ce travail de
Constant amélioration dont parcoursup a
encore besoin aujourd'hui j'en suis
pleinement consciente et je voulais vous
le dire dès le début je vous remercie
merci
madame la ministre dans la suite du
débat la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
dozu pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues et je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier le groupe communiste
pour l'inscription de ce débat essentiel
à notre notre ordre du jour il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire sur le système
dont nous faisons le bilan aujourd'hui
celui de parcoursup créé par la loi
relative à lamentation et la Russie des
étudiants de mars 2018 parcoursup à
organiser le système d'admission dans
les formations d'enseignement supérieur
pour la quatrième année et la quatrième
rentrée cette année destinée à remplacer
le système d'admission peau de post-bac
APB le nouveau système se voulait plus
efficace et plus juste celles et ceux
qui en parlent le mieux sont les
étudiantes et les étudiants et l'étude
Ipsos réalisée chaque année sur plus de
1000 néo bacheliers à ce sujet permet
d'avoir un aperçu de l'expérience
utilisateur pour reprendre les termes de
la startup nation les résultats sont
sans appel si 74% des interrogés
trouvaient le système fiable en 2020 il
n'était plus que 66 en 2021 et 57 en
2022 c'est la même chose et même pire
pour l'équité du système 48%
vrai que parcoursup était juste en 2020
ils ne sont plus que 28% en 2022
idem pour la transparence 60% en 2020
48% en 2022
et le seul indicateur en constante
augmentation est celui du stress généré
par les fûts pour les futurs étudiants
77% étaient stressés par le système en
2020 contre 83 % en 2022 en résumé pour
les lycéens aujourd'hui parcours
subtennifiable nijust ni transparent à
peine la moitié trouve qu'il lui permet
d'exprimer ses besoins et huit lycéens
sur 10 le vif comme un stress alors on
entend souvent dire que parcoursup et
perfectible mais ces chiffres nous
indiquent plutôt que tout est à revoir
d'autant que les derniers répondants
sont les premiers qui ont vécu tout le
lycée de la seconde à la terminale avec
ce système pour reprendre les raisons
les pour comprendre les raisons du rejet
grandissant souvent le capot et
reprenons pas point par point les deux
objectifs que s'étaient fixés les
inspirateurs de ce système efficacité et
justice en d'autres termes parcours sup
permet-il efficacement de construire un
parcours d'études choisi pour un ou une
bachelière concernant l'efficacité cette
notion est plus que discutable là où le
système est qui était plutôt médiocre
d'APB proposer une hiérarchisation de 24
choix de filière pour les futurs
étudiants avec trois phases admissions à
date fixe et un algorithme assez obscur
parcoursup ne permet que 10 choix par
candidats qui seront depuis cette année
seulement hiérarchisés avec des réponses
qui peuvent intervenir à tout moment et
demande la confirmation en moins de 5
jours une sélection avec des algorithmes
locaux différents selon les ufs le tout
est organisé en plusieurs phases une
principale une complémentaire à une
saisine possible une commission Adobe
pour les restants à la fin du processus
le résultat est provisé et prévisible
pour une bonne partie des étudiants les
choix sont souvent faits par défaut
anticipant des critères de sélection
flou ou opaque et mal accompagnés
auxquels s'ajoutent des délais d'attente
parfois impossible qui engendre un
stress permanent au terme de la première
phase de sélection mi-juillet environ
10% des candidats soit plus de 90 000
personnes se retrouvent toujours sans
affectation
sur la justice du système ensuite qui
est à mon sens véritablement le cœur du
problème parcoursup les chaque UFR
établir ses critères critères qui on
pouvait en douter sans douter pardon
sont basés principalement sur les notes
mais aussi sur les lycées d'origine ou
encore sur les outils automatisés d'aide
à la décision pour ne pas dire d'aide à
la sélection la Cour des comptes a
décrit je cite un fonctionnement
nébuleux des commissions d'examens des
vœux et des critères de plus en plus
automatisés et demandent de rendre
public des algorithmes utilisés par ces
commissions pour l'ensemble des
formations il y aurait beaucoup à dire
notamment sur l'incapacité de parcoursup
à combler les manques des services
administratifs en sous-effectif
chronique depuis des années sur le poids
qui pèse en terme horaire sur les
équipes éducatives qui doivent s'occuper
maintenant des procédures de classement
sur le marché pieds qui constitue la
plateforme pour les formations privées
sur le coût exorbitant du dispositif
mais si l'on s'en tient au seul attendus
de départ efficacité justice on peut
dire on peut déjà conclure un double
échec madame la ministre il est temps
d'écouter les futurs étudiants le
système actuel est un système de tri
souvent arbitraire qui un certain nombre
de parcours et de filières à de très
nombreuses étudiants et ouvrent les
portes des filières privées au-delà
d'une réforme en profondeur des
procédures d'admission et de
l'enseignement supérieur ouvrons et
investissons ouvrons de nouvelles
filières en adéquation avec les
aspirations grandissant des étudiants
pour le savoir du monde de demain
investissons massivement dans notre
université notre recherche publique en
développement les campus en créant de
nouvelles unités de formation pour
accueillir les bacheliers dans les
filières qu'ils souhaitent et non pas
dans les filières par défaut
l'université de demain est un idéal qui
doit préfigurer la société de demain
inclusive égalitaire solidaire
parcoursup nos contribue pas à nous
mener vers cette université au service
de l'émancipation il nous en écarte
c'est pourquoi il est temps de le
repenser de fond en comble je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices donc bien entendu croyez
Monsieur le Sénateur vous êtes contre
vous l'avez dit vous vous êtes contre et
vous êtes même contre le fait de garder
parcoursup et moi aujourd'hui je suis
pour l'améliorer pour continuer à
améliorer une plateforme qui existe
depuis 5 ans où nous avons un retour
d'expérience depuis 5 ans plutôt que de
mettre à nouveau une nouvelle plateforme
pour accompagner nos étudiants vers la
réussite vous avez cité des chiffres
effectivement il y a eu ce rapport
Ipsos que nous avons chaque année où
vous pouvez comparer les chiffres je
voudrais vous en citer aussi qui sort du
même rapport et l'évolution de ces
chiffres est plutôt positif partout vous
regardez en grande majorité au cours de
ces années une large majorité des
lycéens aujourd'hui apprécient le fait
de retrouver sur parcoursup toutes les
formations reconnues par l'État
89%, c'est vraiment un outil de vitrine
de nos formations accessible pour tous
de tous les étudiants et de toute la
France et la liberté de formuler leurs
vœux
86%. les indicateurs liés à la phase
d'admission progressent également 72%
sont satisfaits des réponses des
formations à leurs vœux c'est plus de
points par rapport à 2021 et 68 % sont
satisfaits des délais de réponse 4
points par rapport à 2021 aujourd'hui
c'est délai pour la première proposition
sont liées sont au bout de 4,2 jours
pour les étudiants alors oui et j'en
suis consciente je vous l'ai dit il y a
des améliorations à faire et avec mon
collègue Pape Ndiaye nous allons y
travailler pour l'orientation pour
améliorer l'arientation pour diminuer ce
ressenti de stress mais stress qui est
quelque part lié à l'avenir de ces
jeunes donc une partie du stress je
dirais normal et une autre sur lequel
nous devons agir pour les accompagner je
voudrais vous dire que aujourd'hui les
10 feux sont faits pour les étudiants
sans hiérarchie des vœux afin que
l'étudiant jusqu'au bout et le choix de
la formation qui lui ont proposé alors
kap B vous choisissiez à 10 vœux en
février et vous aviez le neuvième vœu
sans savoir si votre dixième était pris
en juin juillet aujourd'hui c'est une
amélioration qui place l'étudiant au
centre et ce système ce n'est pas un
système d'algorithme c'est un système de
choix ou l'humain est au centre puisque
c'est comités d'examens sont avec des
enseignants des enseignants du supérieur
en lien avec les lycées et qui sont là
je peux vous le dire pour avoir pendant
30 ans était à leur côté être là pour le
bien de nos élèves le bien de nos
étudiants et nous allons y travailler
avec eux merci
merci madame la ministre je sais que
nous apprécions que vous répondiez
systématiquement je vous demande juste
d'être vigilante sur les deux minutes
pour que tout le monde puisse voilà mais
on apprécie d'avoir une ministre qui
réponde c'est pas toujours le cas
non non je donnerai pas de nom
la parole est à Madame Nicole Duranton
pour le groupe RDPI
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues quel bilan
pour parcoursup retour d'expérience
depuis sa création en 2018 la plateforme
fonctionne de mieux en mieux comme vous
l'avez rappelé madame la ministre créé
parcoursup créé par la loi relative à
l'orientation et à la réussite des
étudiants du 8 mars 2018 c'est en effet
un système qui peut être encore amélioré
grâce au retour d'expérience mais dont
les carences on est en moins été
corrigés par le ministère chaque année
il est impossible d'obtenir un résultat
parfait dès les premières années mais le
gouvernement a su garder une oreille
attentive et prendre en compte les
demandes des utilisateurs comme vous le
savez les lycéens ou étudiants en
recherche d'une réorientation y compris
sous statut apprenti ont ainsi accès à
plus de 21000 formations supérieures
dont plus de 7000 en apprentissage si la
officielles ouvrira pour cette année le
20 décembre les jeunes peuvent d'ores et
déjà comme vous l'avez indiqué se
connecter à la plateforme pour y
découvrir les formations cette première
phase de novembre avant le conseil de
classe est essentiel pour que chacun
puisse préciser l'idée qu'il fait de son
futur cette information constitue le
premier degré de l'égalité des chances
les établissements sont encore en train
de calibrer leur présentation en 2022 la
plateforme a connu 936 000 candidats
dont 622
000 lycéens on a pu entendre que
parcoursup ne leur laisse pas assez de
choix
11,6 millions de vœux et souveux ont été
formés pour des formations en statut
étudiant soit plus de 12 vœux en moyenne
par élève on a pu entendre que
parcoursup n'accompagnait pas tous les
jeunes et que certains étaient laissés
pour compte pourtant
l'issue de la face principale les
candidats sans proposition peuvent
solliciter l'accompagnement des
commissions d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur qui conseille les recteurs on
a pu entendre que parcoursup était trop
opaque or les jurys doivent désormais
produire un rapport public sur les
critères ayant motivé les décisions
d'admission mais surtout de
non-admission des lycéens on a pu
entendre encore que parcoursup ne
compensez pas suffisamment les
inégalités structurelles entre les
catégories socio-professionnelles et les
territoires notamment dans la ruralité
en effet comme le rappelle la Fédération
des territoires aux grandes écoles qui
agit directement auprès des lycéens des
territoires ruraux 17% des lycéens
généraux et technologiques fournissent à
eux la seule moitié seule la moitié des
effectifs des grandes écoles les élèves
parisiens ont trois fois plus de chances
d'accéder aux études qu'ils appellent de
leurs vœux c'est une réalité et
parcoursup en tentant de valoriser les
dossiers et l'expérience personnelle de
chacun porte aussi cet objectif il faut
un système national ambitieux comme ce
dispositif si l'on veut que l'égalité
des chances soit réelle que propose les
détracteurs de parcoursup en
remplacement un système fondé seulement
sur les bulletins scolaires qui
négligent les parcours individuels un
système linéaire laissant la main à
l'arbitraire un système de recrutement
totalement ouvert où chaque école fait
son marché et qui créerait une confusion
totale
souvenons-nous souvenons-nous nous
qu'avant parcoursup nous avions
admission post-bac qui est pour le coup
qui était très complexe déclaration de
24 vœux tirage au sort algorithme mal
calibré manque d'informations autant de
défauts qui faisaient de l'orientation
des lycéens un véritable parcours du
combattant et qui a été largement
critiquée sur parcours les vœux ne sont
plus classés les établissements étudient
tous les dossiers reçus et l'étudiant
peut se réserver le droit d'attendre une
proposition qui l'estime plus
intéressante le moteur de recherche
favorise la mobilité des étudiants et
leur capacités de choix l'abandon du
principe de classement des voeux a
permis au boursier de moins
s'autocensurer doit-on regretter les
files d'attente devant les universités
doit-on regretter le tirage au sort
d'APB parcoursup apporte une réponse
efficace à ces deux défauts mes chers
collègues
overont ensemble à améliorer parcoursup
au service de notre jeunesse au lieu de
critiquer ce fameux algorithme alors que
ce sont belles et bien des agents qui
travaillent derrière cette plateforme
madame la ministre en juillet dernier
lors d'une séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vous
interroge au sujet des lycéens qui
n'avaient pas encore reçu de réponse
favorable
toujours parcoursup vous m'aviez alors
souligné que ce n'était pas qu'un outil
mais aussi un processus humain avec
l'accompagnement de tous nos élèves par
des milliers d'enseignants et
professionnels de l'orientation en lycée
et dans les rectorats neuf lycées 1 sur
10 avaient alors reçu au moins une
proposition vous aviez très justement
affirmé qu'il est bien d'entrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur mais qu'il faut
surtout réussir or en deux ans entre
2018 et 2020 le taux de réussite en
premier cycle et en licence est passé de
40 à 45% et le taux des boursiers de 20
à 25%. c'est une réussite dont je me
félicite ainsi que mon groupe le RDPI
cette réussite reste perfectible mais la
procédure a déjà gagné en transparence
et en lisibilité en 2022 la phase
principale a été accélérée pour
améliorer le temps de réponse aux
candidats votre projet madame la
ministre pour la cession 2023 et
d'améliorer l'objectivité du processus
et sa lisibilité madame la ministre où
en est-on aujourd'hui du développement
des améliorations continues prévues sur
cette plateforme parcoursup qui évolue
dans le bon sens depuis sa création je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Nicole Duranton d'abord merci
tout d'abord pour vos propos qui
permettent effectivement de restituer
les enjeux les progrès et les
améliorations
parcoursup n'est qu'une plateforme c'est
vrai et bien des responsabilités sont en
jeu dans l'accès à cet enseignement
supérieur il ne faut pas le cacher et
c'est pour cela que le travail
d'amélioration en continu que vous avez
évoqué doit être menée avec toutes les
parties prenantes du secondaire et du
supérieur parcoursup a fait des progrès
et engager des améliorations pour mieux
servir d'abord les intérêts des jeunes
et écouter les étudiants nous le faisons
depuis cinq ans et les lycéens dans
l'étude d'opinion publiée en septembre
en témoigne aussi
oui madame madame la sénatrice
l'accompagnement à l'orientation au
lycée existe et nous allons continuer à
l'améliorer oui parcoursup apporte des
informations pour faire son choix et là
aussi des cette année des progrès
arrivent oui les délais de réponse se
sont améliorés et nous allons diminuer
ces délais ainsi que la transparence des
critères pour parcoursup je voudrais
vous dire aussi que cette année il ne
restait que 160 étudiants après les KS
plus que 33 après les avoir suivis un
par un pour leur intégration dans
l'enseignement nous nous engageons donc
à continuer ces améliorations sur toutes
ces volets dès 2023 et sur les quatre
axes stratégiques que je vous
présenterai
merci la parole est maintenant à Madame
Sylvie Robert pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tentez de tirer un
bilan constructif de parcoursup conduit
à éviter deux écueils un optimisme
débridé devant la capacité de l'outil à
apparier un nombre important d'étudiants
avec de multiples formations sans même
questionner la pertinence de cet
appariement et à laverse une critique
sans mesure qui est tant à confondre
l'algorithme parcoursup avec la
procédure parcoursup en somme évitez
tout manichéisme j'aborderai donc ce
débat à travers une problématique
générale de quoi parcoursup de par ses
sous-jacents et modalités et ses
implications est-il finalement le
révélateur en matière d'orientation des
jeunes
si nous nous référons à la loi originale
de 2018 la création de parcoursup
répondait à un double objectif mieux
orienter et garantir la réussite des
étudiants l'orientation étant la
condition sinequanone de cette réussite
or en l'état je crois que parcoursup
révèle la prédominance d'une conception
de l'orientation celle de la pariement
celle de la gestion urgente des flux
étant donné la démographie étudiantine
conséquence directe les étudiants n'ont
plus nécessairement le choix de leur
orientation ils peuvent d'ailleurs
parfois le subir en particulier
lorsqu'ils se destine aux filières en
tension
leur liberté de choix devient alors
conditionnel et c'est une réalité que
notre groupe n'a une cesse de dénoncer
qui va rebours de ce préconiser le
Césaire dans son rapport de 2018 sur
l'orientation des jeunes il n'est pas
admissible que le manque de place dans
certaines formations contraignent les
étudiants à accepter des choix parfois
éloignés de leurs vœux premiers
malheureusement et mécaniquement cette
tendance est aussi de plus en plus
prégnante à l'entrée en master ainsi
parcoursup révèle
l'institutionnalisation d'une sélection
partielle à l'entrée dans le supérieur
pour endiguer la pénurie de place
résultant du manque de moyens pour la
justifier certains ont avancé qu'il
valait mieux cette sélection que l'échec
qui prévalait en licence auparavant je
répondrai que ni la généralisation de
l'échec ni la généralisation de la
sélection de son souhaitable
et s'il était insatisfaisant de se
reposer uniquement sur le principe des
galaxies au supérieures sans oeuvrer
concrètement à la réussite de chaque
étudiant il est tout aussi inacceptable
de fermer a priori certaines portes de
certaines filières censées être ouverte
à tous et toutes dès lors que la
sélection est de mise l'enjeu de son
acceptabilité par les candidats devient
central c'est pourquoi l'évolution vers
le système parcoursup a entraîné des
modifications des transformations
parfois positives dans les modalités
d'orientation des jeunes la politique
d'orientation commence à se structurer
autour d'un continu un continuum pardon
bac moins 1 bac plus -3 + 3 et en ce
sens la mise en place de parcoursup doit
impérativement se lire à l'aune de la
réforme du baccalauréat
en termes d'orientation les
améliorations sont de deux ordres en
amont il y a une vraie amélioration de
l'information mais vous l'avez dit
Madame la Ministre mis à disposition des
candidats parcourt sup est un portail
parfois vertigineux d'ailleurs qui
comprend des attendus nationaux locaux
pour chaque formation leur taux
d'insertion professionnelle etc
cependant il convient de ne pas omettre
que rendre accessible l'information ne
signifie aucunement qu'elle sera
décryptée comme il se doit d'où
l'importance une fois de plus de
l'accompagnement dans la orientation et
on avale le début n'accompagne d'un
accompagnement personnalisé en licence
avec les whis sur ce point madame la
ministre il serait opportun d'avoir une
évaluation nationale sur la mise en
oeuvre des whis dans les établissements
du supérieur pour analyser les freins
ainsi que peut-être les aménagements
auxquels procéder pour rendre le
dispositif plus opérant rappelons que le
législateur est singulièrement au Sénat
vous rappelez mes chers collègues à
concéder la création de parcoursup sous
réserve de objectivité de ces modules
complémentaires devant permettre aux
étudiants de se mettre à niveau pour
suivre l'orientation de leur choix pour
ma part je pense que c'est
accompagnement doit être encore plus
renforcé plus personnalisé car il est la
clé de la réussite des étudiants
d'autre part parcoursup révèle un
changement profond en matière de
responsabilité dans le processus
d'orientation d'aucun d'ailleurs ont
évoqué un transfert de responsabilité
d'abord vers les universités les équipes
pédagogiques qui à travers les
commissions d'examens des vœux sont
maintenant responsables de la sélection
qu'elles peuvent effectuer et elles font
un travail vous l'avez dit à la ménis
c'est vrai très important qu'on peut
saluer ce changement de paradigme
corollaire de autonomisation croissante
des universités explique le combat que
nous avons mené en faveur de la
transparence des algorithmes des locaux
combats portés en commun cher Pierre
ouzulia de pas mal pendant pas mal
d'années je me réjouis l'obligation qui
est désormais en fait qui est désormais
faite aux établissements de publier
exposent un rapport d'examen des vœux
faisant état des critères qui ont
présidé à la décision il est indéniable
que la transparence a progressé de
depuis 2018 malgré les déni et refus
répétés je peux le dire de la précédente
ministre mais elle peut encore être
affermie sans pour autant porter
atteinte au secret des délibérations
se transperce au perd aussi vers les
étudiants qui sont rendus encore plus
responsables de leur orientation deux
lectures complémentaires sont possibles
à cet endroit l'une méliorative obligée
les étudiants à penser leur projet
d'orientation plutôt au lycée à le
formaliser de manière plus détaillée
explicite et positive cela les rend
encore plus acteurs de leur orientation
les conduits à se l'approprier et
facilitent la transition vers le
supérieur je pense notamment aux projets
de formation motivés ou même à l'affiche
à venir l'autre plus nuancée dès lors
que nous résonnons concrètement dans le
monde de parcoursup tout se passe comme
si les étudiants étaient égaux devant
l'orientation or les sociologues de
l'éducation dont démontré depuis
longtemps en l'espèce comme dans nombre
de domaines nul l'égalité réelle ne
prévaut et d'ailleurs la mission
d'évaluation de l'excès à l'enseignement
supérieur de 2020 réalisé par
l'Assemblée nationale le citron pas
si l'octroi d'un second professeur
principal notamment dédié à
l'orientation la consécration de deux
semaines destinées à l'orientation en
terminale et la mise en réserve de 54
heures sur l'ensemble du lycée son
bénéfique leur application et leur
contenu sont parfois très inégaux et
très aléatoires pire beaucoup de
professeurs principaux ne cessent ne
s'estime pas suffisamment formés si bien
que plusieurs académies ont fait part de
leurs difficultés de recrutement
beaucoup de chefs d'établissement aussi
pensent de voir être formés à
l'orientation ces statistiques
expliquent pour vous près d'un tiers des
lycéens non parfois pas bénéficié de
conseils au moment de leur choix
d'orientation dans ce contexte il est
plus aisé de comprendre le sentiment
d'injustice et d'amertume qui peut
saisir les étudiants lorsqu'ils sont
refusés dans la formation de leur choix
parce que finalement ils se retrouvent
responsables d'un échec qui n'est
pourtant pas le leur naturellement
parcoursup n'est pas la seule cause de
ce déficit dans l'accompagnement dans
l'orientation des élèves c'est la raison
pour laquelle on introduction
souvenez-vous j'ai plutôt évoqué
parcoursup comme un révélateur peut-être
plus que tout autre considération
parcoursup révèle finalement le lourd
investissement qu'il reste à réaliser
pour structurer et améliorer encore
notre politique d'orientation qui a
constitué depuis des décennies un talon
d'Achille de nos politiques publiques
car la politique d'orientation et le
viatique par lequel lutter efficacement
contre les déterminismes de toute nature
et par lequel accroître la mobilité
sociale elle est d'autant plus Indis
responsable que le système de
l'enseignement supérieur se caractérise
par une forte étanchéité entre les
filières lesquelles sont hérités du
secondaire et par des passerelles encore
trop rares si la politique d'orientation
n'est ni proactive ni corrective ni
compensatoire alors les étudiants se
retrouvent enfermés dans une trajectoire
qui ne peuvent plus maîtriser et la
moindre inflexion peut jouer chers
collègues mais je ne vais pas m'étendre
la réforme de l'enseignement des
mathématiques au lycée regardez les
conséquences qu'il y a eu très vite et
très profonde en réalité l'orientation
ne s'arrête pas au continent moins 3 + 3
elle s'avère un processus long complexe
intime parfois liée aux conditions
personnelles de chaque élève le Césaire
dans son rapport avait parfaitement
intégré cette dimension en préconisant
de passer de procédures ponctuelles un
parcours progressif ce qui implique tout
au long de la scolarité un travail de
déconstruction des déterminisme sociaux
et un accompagnement personnalisé de
chaque élève pour construire son futur
désirable
alors en conclusion je voudrais vous
dire que le caractère vital de cet
accompagnement est d'autant plus fort
que les chercheurs ont mis en exerg à
quel point dans le secteur de
l'éducation les inégalités se
sédimentent se cumulent atteignant
parfois leurs paroxysme leur paroxysme
au moment de la procédure car parcoursup
peut matérialiser justement toutes ces
inégalités passées et dans certains cas
les reproduire autrement dit parcoursup
pourrait être le produit de notre
système scolaire alors l'enjeu est
primordial madame la ministre car elle
concerne un investissement massif dans
notre politique d'orientation mais aussi
dans l'enseignement supérieur c'est un
enjeu démocratique majeur je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Sylvie Robert d'abord vraiment
merci merci infiniment pour votre
intervention qui pour moi pose au fond
les vrais enjeux de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur ou en tout cas
parmi certains enjeux que vous avez
relevés en particulier sur la politique
d'orientation inscrire l'accompagnement
à l'orientation au centre du dispositif
cela du dispositif cela exprimé notre
conviction que pour être en tout point
démocratique notre système éducatif
devait effectivement faire le choix de
donner une vraie visibilité à
l'éducation à l'orientation et à l'aide
au choix des professeurs principaux vous
l'avez dit ont été désignés en classe de
terminale des ressources ont déjà été
développées et cela se voit dans les
lycées comme en témoignent les études
d'opinion ou le progrès que nous avons
vu jusqu'à présent mais bien sûr il faut
faire mieux en accompagnant en
accompagnant beaucoup de monde mais
effectivement davantage les professeurs
principaux en les aidant en quelque
sorte à accompagner leurs élèves qui
s'intéressent à leur formation post-bac
dès les premières années au lycée c'est
l'ambition que nous avons que nous
donnons avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et nous y travaillons en
particulier avec l'Onisep alors je
voudrais aussi revenir vous avez dit
donc sur cet accompagnement cette
orientation on va y travailler je
voudrais revenir sur le bilan des whis
le bilan des whis est effectivement
quelque chose de qui sera fait
d'important dans le cadre de ce
développement du lien -3+3 et
oserais-je dire avec un focus
particulier sur le plus sain à l'entrée
de l'université ou dans dans le
supérieur je voudrais vous dire que 1700
dispositifs où ici aujourd'hui et 2700
étudiants en bénéficiant en 2022 mais
une vraie évaluation doit être fait je
vous rejoins aussi sur la notion de
d'entre elles aujourd'hui nos étudiants
ne peuvent pas avoir un parcours
linéaire et un parcours de réussite
c'est un parcours d'accompagnement fait
de passerelles d'écoute et de suivi je
vous remercie et nous continuerons à
travailler dans ce sens et à votre
analyse merci beaucoup
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
notre collègue Céline Brulin pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les résultats de la
plateforme parcoursup sont désolants le
ministère a beau indiqué que seuls
lycéens n'ont pas trouvé de place ce
sont en fait plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de bacheliers qui n'ont pu
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur cette
année
parcoursup est un instrument de gestion
de la pénurie au sein de l'enseignement
supérieur depuis 2008 le budget par
étudiant ne cesse de baisser et le taux
d'encadrement de régresser entre 2012 et
2017 seul 19 universités sur 68 ont vu
la part des enseignants titulaires
augmentaient et seulement 12 d'entre
elles leur taux d'encadrement
s'améliorer timidement cela a de lourdes
conséquences pour toute la société ainsi
alors que nous manquons de médecins dans
de plus en plus de nos territoires alors
qu'il y a pourtant une véritable
affluence des candidatures pour les
l'habitude de santé sur parcoursup
puisqu' avec les études enfin avec les
instituts en soins infirmiers se sont
celles qui sont les plus demandées les
capacités d'accueil dans nos universités
empêchent non seulement des jeunes
d'épouser des carrières auxquelles ils
aspirent mais également de lutter
efficacement contre la désertification
médicale et la saturation de notre
système public d'enseignement supérieur
pousse de plus en plus d'élèves à se
tourner vers des formations privées 25%
des étudiants du supérieur ils sont
inscrits et rien que pour l'année
2021-2022 le marché privé de
l'Enseignement supérieur a progressé de
10% quand le périmètre de l'université
ne le faisait que de
0,4%. parcoursup est aussi un système
qui accroît les inégalités
ces inégalités dont la réforme du lycée
et du bac renforce que la réforme du
lycée du Mac renforce en faisant peser
sur les épaules d'adolescents de 15-16
ans la responsabilité du choix des
disciplines de spécialité afin qu'elle
correspondent aux attendus de
l'établissement d'enseignement supérieur
qu'ils soient intégrer et les 54 heures
d'orientation dispensées par les profs
principaux sont d'un bien maigre secours
face à cela selon une enquête de
l'Observatoire de la vie étudiante 56%
des étudiants de classes populaires
indiquent leurs proches ou leur famille
ont permis de construire leur choix
d'orientation ils sont 76% dans le cas
des classes dominantes le constat fait
par le Conseil d'analyse économique est
implacable un jeune issu d'une famille
aisée à trois fois plus de chances
d'accéder à l'enseignement supérieur
qu'un jeune
issu d'une famille ou revenu modeste
disparité entre jeunes donc disparité
aussi entre université
celle de Paris 1 voit le nombre de Néo
bacheliers avec mention qu'elle
accueille progresser significativement à
l'inverse la part de ceux qui ont plus
de 19 ans 10 minutes l'université d'Evry
voit elle diminuer sa part de Néo
bachelier généraux ainsi que ceux avec
mention on pourrait aussi évoquer les
bacheliers des filières professionnelles
qui acceptent de plus en plus rarement à
la licence avec une baisse notable de
ces derniers dans les filières STAPS
certains diront sans doute que nous
avons une lecture idéologique de
parcoursup et de ses algorithmes alors
ayons-en une lecture pragmatique et
voyons si la plateforme assure la
régulation des métiers dont notre
société a besoin et bien pas davantage
le récent rapport de notre collègue
Catherine de roche et de la commission
d'enquêtes sénatoriales sur la situation
de l'hôpital a montré par exemple que
les candidats à l'entrée en institut de
formation une fois infirmier était prêt
de 690 000 en 2021 contre 180000 il y a
quatre ans lorsqu'il existait le
concours de quoi résorber la pénurie de
soignants que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et bien au contraire on
connaît actuellement un taux d'abandon
sans précédent durant la formation qui
alimente qui alimente la pénurie la trop
faible mixité dans certaines filières la
ségrégation sociale à l'oeuvre sont en
effet un problème qui dépasse largement
la seule éthique 2000 bacheliers
issus du bac pro techno ST2S par exemple
si on se technologie de la santé du
social ce qui représente quand même plus
de 20% des effectifs de ce bac se sont
retrouvés exclus en 2019 via parcoursup
de la formation d'infirmiers à laquelle
il s'était pourtant destiné en
choisissant précisément ce baccalauréat
combien d'autres ont connu le même sort
depuis il nous manque aujourd'hui
notamment dans nos hôpitaux
de même pour ce qui concerne les études
de médecine nous ne résorberons pas les
déserts médicaux qui gagnent nos villes
moyennes et nos zones rurales tant que
seront quasi exclusivement des jeunes
issus des filières scientifiques ayant
obtenu leur bac avec mention très bien
et grandit dans les métropoles ou les
villes universitaires qui y accéderont
la démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur et donc une nécessité pour
répondre aux besoins de notre pays tout
comme l'investissement massif dont il
doit faire l'objet
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président
maisdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrice madame la sénatrice Céline
Brulin alors je ne ferai pas de bataille
de chiffres car vous le savez comme pour
vous comme pour moi chaque étudiant est
important donc peu importe 60 nous
essayons de les gérer un tous vous posez
la question des inégalités d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur vaste question
vous comprendrez peut-être que ces
inégalités existaient bien avant
parcoursup et je mets même essayé non
pas de vous convaincre mais de vous
montrer que parcoursup apporte une
contribution à ce défi aussi de
l'égalité d'accès et de réussite des
étudiants ne serait-ce qu'en mettant à
disposition de tous les mêmes
informations et les mêmes opportunités
de faire des vœux librement madame
Duranton l'a rappelé entre 2018 et 21 le
taux des lycéens boursiers admis sur
parcoursup à progressé de 5 points de 25
à 25%. grâce au taux de boursier
voulu par la loi de 2018 et gérer par
parcoursup pour 2022 ce sont près de
12300 lycées en boursiers qui ont été
admis dans la formation de leur choix et
qui n'auraient pu être admis sans les
taux de priorité instaurés par la loi
ore orientation réussite étudiante il y
a des exemples très concrets
l'intégration sur parcoursup de Sciences
Po Paris a permis d'attirer davantage de
boursiers on compte parmi les ennemis
12% de boursiers du secondaire en 2022
contre 5% en 2020 et 3,8 des ennemis de
2019 pour lutter contre cette
auto-censure nous avons aussi promu les
parcours des élèves en cordée de la
réussite auprès des formations cela a
aussi eu des effets tangibles 6,7 points
de taux de proposition pour les
bacheliers professionnels en cordée de
la réussite par rapport à ces mêmes
lycéens hors-cordés je fais
effectivement moi aussi de l'égalité
d'accès de réussite les étudiants ma
priorité et c'est pour cela que nous
avons fait le choix avec parcoursup de
la priorité donnée bacheliers
technologiques à l'accès au but de la
priorité donnée aux bacheliers pro pour
l'accès au BTS et du soutien de 500
euros à la mobilité des lycéens
boursiers ainsi que du droit aux réama
avec la pluie du recteur pour les
candidats en situation de handicap et je
pourrais vous en citer d'autres et je
suis prête à travailler bien sûr merci
merci madame la ministre
donc la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Jean engrais pour le groupe
Union centriste
grands résultats au bac elle souhaite
faire une double licence en droit et en
sciences politiques à Rennes ville qui
n’est pourtant pas dans son secteur elle
a donc été classée de millièmes sur la
liste d'attentes l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur cristallise de
nombreux inquiétudes et
incompréhensibles
des questions immédiates sur la
formation souhaitée ou l'organisation de
la vie étudiante se pose donc la
question de l'avenir de nos jeunes ils
sont pas ils ont parfois le sentiment de
faire des choix importants sans pour
autant maîtriser tous les paramètres de
leur décision pour tenter de répondre à
ces enjeux parcoursup a été mis en place
en 2018 en remplaçant en remplacement du
dispositif admission post-bac depuis son
lancement de nombreux élus notamment au
Sénat ont appelé le gouvernement sur les
difficultés rencontrées par les élèves
et leurs professeur lors de son
utilisation sur l'opacité des
algorithmes de la plateforme ou encore
sur l'anxiété provoquée par la procédure
en ligne
en septembre 2022 82 % des bacheliers
déclaré avoir trouvé la procédure trop
stressante bref après quatre années
d'existence le système demeure pro trop
peu compréhensible et difficilement
lisible si l'on ne regrette pas les
écueils d'admission post-bac comme le
tirage au sort ou encore les fils
d'attente devant la fac ou le premier
arrivé était le premier inscrit le
dispositif parcoursup est plus largement
l'orientation de nos élèves de terminale
doit être repensée
tout d'abord je pense à l'accompagnement
à l'orientation qui est la clé de voûte
de la réforme du lycée mais qui est le
parent pauvre de l'éducation nationale
avant même que les élèves n'inscrivent
ne s'inscrivent sur la plateforme nous
constatons un déficit de formation des
professeurs alors même que ce sont eux
qui ont la charge d'accompagner leurs
élèves dans leurs orientation selon la
Cour des comptes en 2020 de nombreux
professeurs et proviseurs déclarait
n'avoir reçu aucune formation spécifique
qui pourrait exercer leur mission
d'orientation les récents modules mis en
place par les rectorats à la suite de la
loi d'orientation à la réussite des
étudiants concernent principalement les
points pratiques et ceci au détriment de
l'accompagnement et du conseil aux
élèves dans leur choix de formation et
de métier faire de l'orientation une
matière à part entière avec des
accompagnants spécifiquement formés
peut-être une prise une piste de
réflexion pour être plus efficace
ensuite les heures destinées à
l'orientation intégrer à la dotation
horaire globale qui servent trop souvent
d'heures d'ajustement pour
l'enseignement des spécialités trop
souvent une fois les heures de
spécialités d'options posées il ne reste
quasiment plus rien pour faire de
l'orientation
ce système renforce les inégalités
territoriales entre les établissements
ayant une culture de l'orientation et
d'autres moins mobilisés sur ces
problématiques il peut également être
une source d'inégalité sociale avec
l'émergence de coach privé en
orientation le passage du système
d'admission post-bac a parcoursup a fait
passer les élèves d'une logique
d'affectation et une logique de
classement alors qu'admission post-bac
demandé à chaque lycéen un classement a
priori de ses vœux pour l'enseignement
supérieur parcoursup mais fin ce système
de hiérarchisation dès le début de la
procédure le lycéen doit désormais
effectuer de nombreux choix sans pour
autant indiquer ses préférences son
affectation semble davantage dépendre de
sa place dans les classements de chaque
formation que de son projet
d'orientation ou de sa véritable
motivation
parcoursup a conduit à la mise en place
de plus de 15000 algorithmes remplaçant
des critères objectifs nationaux et non
académiques en l'absence d'harmonisation
nationale comment distinguer deux
dossiers scolaires construits par des
enseignants différents dans des
établissements différents et selon des
critères différents les forces
disparités entre les différents lycées
conduit certaines formations à prendre
en compte les lycées d'origine des
candidats pour effectuer leur classement
sans que l'objectivité de la méthode ne
soit garantie nous sommes donc en droit
de nous interroger sur la pertinence de
certains critères d'évaluation toujours
selon le rapport de la Cour des comptes
il apparaît également que la bonne
information des candidats sur les
critères de classement des formations
qu'elle il prétendent n'est pas complète
les attendus publiées ne semblent pas
toujours correspondre aux critères
retenus par les comics d'examens des
vœux et souvent ces dernières utilisent
des outils informatiques d'aide à la
décision pour effectuer un prêt
classement des étudiants il convient
donc de rendre public les algorithmes
utilisés afin que le dispositif soit
plus transparent l'instauration de cette
nouvelle procédure a conduit un surcroît
de travail très significatif pour les
équipes de l'éducation nationale souvent
pour des opérations administratives sans
aucune plus-value pédagogique dans
l'enseignement supérieur ce sont des
milliers d'enseignants qui examinent des
dossiers dans plus de 15000 formations
enfin le dispositif parcoursup n'a pas
permis de réfléchir à des solutions
pérennes face aux défis que représente
la massification de la population
étudiante et à la nécessité d'accueillir
ces nouveaux bacheliers dans de bonnes
conditions en 50 ans elle est passée de
20% à
79%, sans autant de candidats potentiels
voulant légitimement accéder à des
études supérieures
alors qui est annoncé la mise en place
d'un nouveau dispositif trouve-t-on
master pour les étudiants postulant en
Master 2 nous sommes inquiets vas-tu
suivre la même logique que parcoursup 4
années après la mise en œuvre de
parcoursup les bénéfices de la nouvelle
procédure ion d'orientation sont
difficiles à estimer aujourd'hui le taux
d'échec a l'issue d'une première année
d'études post-bac reste très élevé et
concerne près d'un étudiant sur deux
particulièrement dans les filières non
sélectives aussi nous nous félicitons de
la mise en place d'une mission
d'information sur le dispositif
parcoursup et nous suivrons
intentivement ces travaux et ses
conclusions madame la ministre
l'éducation nationale ne devrait-elle
pas aider les jeunes à trouver leur voie
plutôt que les forcer empruntaient des
voies sans issue je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur Jean agréé alors je ne peux
pas répondre à tout je vais d'ailleurs
pas suivre ma fiche je vais me lancer
comme ceci mais d'abord je voudrais vous
dire que nous avons tous des exemples
dans toi Lucie je ne sais plus de cas
particuliers ma difficulté à moi et ma
mission c'est de s'occuper de tous les
étudiants pas des cas particuliers
uniquement et c'est bien là une des
difficultés vous l'avez aussi dit alors
effectivement l'accompagnement des
enseignants et quelque chose sur
laquelle nous allons travailler cet
accompagnement des enseignants qui veut
dire être à leur écoute leur communiquer
les outils et des outils simples et
faciles d'usage pour enseigner les
hélicéens nous y travaillons et vous le
verrez dans mes propositions je voudrais
aussi rappeler la hiérarchisation des
vœux cette hiérarchisation des feux qui
n'est pas présente dans parcoursup elle
évitait sur APB l'autocensure d'APB
comme je le disais un étudiant qui avait
10 vœux avant et bien s'il était pris
troisième quatrième vœu ne savait même
pas s'il pouvait être pris à ses autres
vœux ça veut dire qu'il décidaient en
février d'un retour qu'il avait en juin
juillet ou septembre un jeune à 17-18
ans je pense pas que cela enfin c'est
plutôt un progrès au niveau de
parcoursup vous avez aussi parlé du
stress induit on le comprend se ressenti
de stress induit que nous avons amélioré
et c'est là aussi un des facteurs
d'amélioration que nous allons essayer
de proposer dès cette année avec mon
collègue alors vous m'avez interpellé en
tant que ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais en tant que ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur je sais de
effectivement orienter les étudiants
vers leur réussite et je peux vous dire
que parcours pour la plateforme de
Master je vous incite à les lire ce que
j'en disais parce que je serai trop long
à expliquer ici mais elle n'est pas du
tout basée sur les principes de
parcoursup mais comme dans parcoursup
elle est d'abord basée sur un principe
humain de Commission d'examen des vœux
des dossiers des étudiants par des
enseignants dont le métier la carrière
et j'oserait dire toute leur vie et là
pour la réussite de tous nos étudiants
je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Bernard fialer du groupe RDSE
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
à l'occasion de la dernière rentrée
scolaire devant les recteurs d'académie
le président de la République a déclaré
je le cite nous rêvons d'une école qui
fasse réussir nos enfants et qui fasse
réussir la France oui la réussite des
enfants est à la fois une histoire
individuelle et une avanceture
collective qui mobilise d'importants
moyens et des politiques publiques qu'il
nous faut sans cesse interroger
sans vouloir anticiper le très proche
examen par le Sénat du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 je soulignerai
simplement qu'avec 59,7 milliards
d'euros l'éducation nationale consomme
la part la plus importante du budget de
l'État si je mets de côté la mission
remboursement et des grèvements un tel
montant nous invite en effet à regarder
presse ce qui marche et ce qui ne marche
pas ce soir il est question de débattre
de l'orientation post-bac une phase
déterminante pour le futur de chacun de
nos jeunes concitoyens dans l'imposant
système de l'éducation nationale quel
bilan pouvons-nous tirer de parcoursup
après quatre années de sa mise en œuvre
si l'on s'en tient au chiffre publié sur
la plateforme 836
000 candidats concernés en 2022 3
millions 8 de propositions d'admission
et 93% de lycéens contentés en face
principale à l'issue de la face
complémentaire sol 160 bacheliers
seraient resté sans proposition c'est
peu c'est mieux que l'année précédente
bien sûr pour les familles concernées
c'est beaucoup on observe toutefois que
les commissions d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur joue bien leur rôle dans
l'accompagnement de ses élèves sans
solution et j'en profite pour saluer
leur travail
parcours suite semble globalement
fonctionner et éviter certains écueils
de l'ancien dispositif APB jugés à
l'époque totalement déshumanisé et trop
complexe cependant si les quotas
d'affectation des élèves sont remplis ce
système d'orientation respecte-t-il un
principe républicain fondamental celui
de l'égalité des chances dans l'accès
aux études supérieures
des orientations ne se traînent ne
seraient-elles pas davantage subi plutôt
que voulu 28% des élèves se déclarent
insatisfaits de leur sort d'admission
dans le supérieur
parcoursup n'évite par la sélection
selon un rapport de la Cour des comptes
de 2020 sur l'orientation des étudiants
certains de mes collègues l'ont rappelé
la façon dont on procède la Commission
d'examen des vœux n'est pas totalement
transparente la publication exposte des
critères retenus à l'issue de la
procédure d'inscription ne suffit pas à
garantir un traitement de non
sélectivité
s'il conseille constitutionnel a donné
raison secret des délibérations des
jurys il serait cependant souhaitable de
définir certains des paramétrages
retenus par la commission d'examen des
vœux et d'en écarter certains je pense
en particulier aux critères du lycée
d'origine parfois utilisée pour le
départage dans les filières non
sélectives en tension
enfin en amont de parcoursup bien que
l'article
L313-1 du code de l'éducation affirme le
droit au conseil en orientation il est
urgent de renforcer la phase
d'information individualisée des élèves
durant leur deux dernières années de
lycée les politiques publiques en la
matière devraient notamment mieux
prendre en compte les difficultés
propres aux élèves des milieux
socialement défavorisés
il existe un phénomène bien connu
d'auto-censure chez les élèves les moins
favorisés quant à leur choix
d'orientation par ailleurs la moitié
d'entre eux se retrouvent seule à saisir
leur donnée sur parcoursup contrairement
aux élèves des milieux favorisés dont
les deux tiers sont épaulés par leurs
parents
pour terminer
mes chers collègues je n'oublie pas le
problème du stress de plus en plus
répandu chez les élèves comme bien-être
évoqués il existait auparavant chez les
lycéens une sorte d'insouciance dont on
a profité certes le système d'entrée à
l'université sur le mode du premier
arrivé premier servi n'était pas juste
cependant l'obtention du bac était
davantage au moment de libération plutôt
que la promesse d'une face d'angoisse en
effet tout comme APB parcoursup suscite
encore beaucoup d'inquiétudes et chez
les parents aussi
mercredi dernier le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
a rappelé devant la commission culture
éducation l'importance du bien-être à
l'école et je partage sa préoccupation
madame la ministre vous le savez depuis
la pandémie l'attente est immense sur
cet aspect de la vie scolaire qui n'est
pas suffisamment prise en compte par
conséquent mon groupe RDSE compte sur
vous pour la mise en œuvre de politique
visant à redonner aux jeunes l'espoir de
tous les possibles
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
si monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bernard fialère croyez le bien
pardon je partage comme vous cet ardente
obligation de faire réussir nos
étudiants de l'égalité des chances et de
l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur et
aussi pour tout cela l'obligation de la
transparence donc on a un outil pour
forcer des enseignants qui profiteraient
dit-on de l'opacité pour faire une
sélection discriminante mais parce que
je crois comme vous que la transparence
peut être un levier pour améliorer
l'accompagnement à l'orientation pour
rendre les résultats de parcoursup plus
prévisible et au final pour réduire ce
stress ce ressenti du stress des lycéens
et nous allions y travailler en ce sens
parcoursup à accompagner depuis 5 ans
les formations pour aller vers plus de
progrès dans la compréhension de ces
critères d'analyse des candidatures là
où il n'y avait rien nous avons créé des
attendus puis l'obligation d'afficher
les critères et nous irons plus loin
comme je l'indiquerai tout à l'heure
dans ma réponse finale approfondir la
transparence évidemment oui mais comme
vous l'avez dit je tiens aussi à
préserver ce secret des lits
délibérations collégiales des
enseignants ce n'est pas un réflexe
corporatif et encore moins la volonté de
sauvegarder l'opacité mais c'est la
conviction que la délibération des
enseignants est un acquis comme vous
l'avez rappelé que le Conseil
constitutionnel a reconnu et la garantie
d'un regard humain et nous évite
l'automatisation que l'acnil avait
d'ailleurs reproché à APB ne tombons pas
collectivement dans cette caricature qui
jette l'eau propre
injustement sur les milliers
d'enseignants qui font l'examen des
dossiers avec détermination et la
volonté chevillée au corps d'accueillir
et de faire réussir leur futur étudiants
je voudrais rappeler la volonté de la
loi hors de parcoursup pour les
étudiants boursiers les FA utiliser la
prise en compte des Cordées de la
réussite et tout l'accompagnement que je
vous présenterai sur les enseignants du
secondaire et aussi les parents d'élèves
où il y aura aussi un axe de travail je
vous remercie et il y aura des progrès à
faire et qui seront fait merci merci
madame la ministre et la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Max Brisson
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier le groupe CRCE
pour ce débat et saluer l'intervention
goliène de Pierre zouliès tout à l'heure
en 2019 au Sénat Jean-Michel Blanquer
déclaré à propos de parcoursup et de la
réforme du baccalauréat pour la première
fois un véritable pont s'est construit
entre l'enseignement supérieur et
l'enseignement secondaire trois ans
après ce pont est-il véritablement en
place on peut en douter pourtant en
2018-2019 une opportunité sans précédent
se dessiner le mécanisme APB était à
bout de souffle et parcoursup par effet
s'imposer pour apaiser l'entrée dans le
cycle des études supérieures avec un
système d'orientation ou le dossier de
l'élève et donc ses capacités étaient
davantage considérées au fond parcoursup
apparaissait comme le moyen de renouer
avec une école méritocratique un moment
où beaucoup de parents crient leur
inquiétude de pouvoir leurs enfants dans
l'incapacité de prendre un ascenseur qui
ne les avait pas eu même conduit là où
une société leur avait au mouvement les
laisser espérer une place c'est bien
dans ce contexte qui est intervenu la
réforme de parcoursup puis celle du
baccalauréat et là c'est bien dans cet
ordre que la réforme a été conduite
malgré les nombreux alertes qui étaient
à leur lancer sur l'inversion du
calendrier des réformes à l'origine des
formats devaient porter sur
l'orientation trois ans après le constat
est implacable comme l'ont montré trois
tours civil Robert et Jean Henri la
dotation horaire qui lui est consacrée
est insuffisante bien souvent ces heures
sont utilisées pour terminer les
programmes de plus des professeurs
manquent de formation et parfois
d'indication pour accompagner les élèves
dans leur choix de spécialité et alors
poursuites d'études
si la réforme est inachevée c'est parce
qu'au lycée elle ne sait pas donner les
moyens de sa réussite de même elle s'est
très inégalement lancée dans
l'enseignement supérieur qui peine à
s'adapter on constate qu'en dehors de
quelques associations de spécialités qui
débouchent sur des parcours construits
de poursuit des études les spécialités
du lycée restent mal articulées avec les
formations de l'enseignement supérieur
seul une petite partie minoritaire des
établissements d'anciens mon supérieur
ont un effet réellement anticiper la
réforme pour prendre en compte des
profils plus diversifiés à l'opposé la
plupart attend pour agir l'arrivée de la
première cote de lycéens ayant éprouvé
cette réforme sur la totalité de leur
scolarité dans le secondaire plus grave
encore dans de nombreuses formations
supérieures les résultats du tronc
commun sont davantage du mis en avant
que les spécialités cela va l'encontre
la réforme cela lui tourne le dos en
effet l'un des objectifs était de faire
émerger des parcours plus personnalisés
incarnés par le choix de spécialité avec
un objectif essentiel celui de la plus
grande réussite des étudiants dans le
supérieur le fossé entre le SUP et le
SCO et définitivement consommé lorsque
l'on sait que plus de la moitié des
élèves abandonne entre la première et la
terminale des spécialités comme science
d'énergie Niort ou numérique et sciences
numériques par crainte ne pas être pris
en classe préparatoire alors même que
les écoles d'ingénieurs sont désireuses
de ces spécialités c'est là que l'on
mesure l'échec de la réforme elle ne me
permet pas au lycéen ce qui était
pourtant son but original de se muet
progressivement en étudiants et de se
donner un maximum de chances c'est là
que l'on mesure l'échec du continuum
lycée licence c'est là que l'on constate
que le pont qui évoquait Jean-Michel
Blanquer entre l'enseignement secondaire
et le supérieur est loin d'être achevé
et c'est donc à l'homme de cet échec
qu'il faut analyser les angoisses des
futurs étudiants et leur famille face à
parcoursup les débats autour des
algorithmes et du fonctionnement
technique de la plateforme les émotions
autour des lycéens sans solution ou du
manque d'accompagnement sont d'abord le
résultat des faiblesses de
l'articulation entre la réforme du
baccalauréat et les attendus de
l'enseignement supérieur certes des
progrès doivent être faits sur le
fonctionnement de la plateforme mais
l'essentiel réside dans une approche
plus large et plus volontariste de
l'orientation des lycéens une réelle
prise en considération du nouveau
baccalauréat par l'enseignement
supérieur dans la définition de ces
attendus et en effet au-delà des enjeux
inhérents à la plateforme parcoursup et
à son fonctionnement c'est bien le
continuum lycée licence bac moins 3 bac
+ 3 qui reste à construire c'est le pont
dont parlait Jean-Michel Blanquer qui
reste à constituer alors madame le
ministre
comment envisagez-vous au-delà des
améliorations du fonctionnement de la
plateforme à travailler avec votre
collègue de l'éducation nationale à
construire ce continent et un système
d'orientation qui permettent de manière
apaisée à des lycéens de trouver dans
l'enseignement supérieur la
profondissement de leur choix au lycée
merci chers collègues ou la parole à
madame la ministre
pardon
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs laissez natrices
alors tout d'abord vous avez évoqué avec
raison l'enjeu de la continuité des
parcours entre l'enseignement scolaire
et l'enseignement supérieur
alors je voudrais d'abord vous dire que
c'est une question qui m'anime depuis
des années aussi au fond je vous dirais
que c'est l'un des grands défis de notre
temps de temps d'avant et de temps
d'aujourd'hui et de demain car ce qui se
joue c'est bien effectivement une
meilleure orientation dans le secondaire
pour sécuriser les parcours des lycéens
mais aussi et vous l'avez dit une plus
grande personnalisation des parcours
dans l'enseignement supérieur pour
favoriser la réussite des étudiants
pendant longtemps le -3 + 3 est resté un
concept une coquille vide ou quelque
chose que l'on essayait d'atteindre avec
parcoursup la réforme du lycée nous
avons ouvert la voie à cette continuité
moins 3 + 3 pour éviter ces ruptures et
je peux vous dire qu'avec monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale nous
avons décidé d'y travailler et de
franchir un pas et là je pose mes fiches
parce que voilà je voudrais vous
répondre parce que je pense que ce que
vous me dites et je vais le résumer
c'est une philosophie de l'enseignement
que nous devrions discuter c'est que
nous sommes au 21e siècle vous avez
parlé du numérique vous avez parlé du
digital je pourrais faire pour vous
parler des sciences pour l'ingénieur de
beaucoup beaucoup de disciplines ou de
compétences ou de connaissance dont un
besoin nos jeunes aujourd'hui et je
pense que c'est plus aujourd'hui que de
revoir la continuité du moins 3 + 3 même
si elle est nécessaire et nous devons y
travailler c'est une philosophie de
comme dirait Montaigne de savoir s'il
faudrait une tête bien faite ou bien
apprendre à apprendre et je peux vous
dire et je peux vous dire que c'est
vraiment
un repenser de ce dont tu as besoin nos
élèves et nos étudiants tout au long de
leur parcours tout au long de leur
métier en connaissance et en compétences
que nous devons apprendre au lycée à
l'université dans les écoles je pense
que c'est un travail de fond que nous
devons mener dans le cadre du moins 3 +
3 mais dans le cadre d'un enseignement
pédagogique du 21e siècle avec des
passerelles et avec une formation qui
doit être une formation tout au long de
la vie et c'est une refonte complète que
nous devons français non seulement dans
le -3+3 je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Jean-Pierre de colle pour
le groupe Les Indépendants
2018 la plateforme parcoursup contribue
à une refonte bienvenue du système
éducatif français il vise à répondre aux
difficultés d'accès aux études
supérieures après quatre ans
d'exploitation la plateforme continue à
répondre à la mission que le Parlement
et le gouvernement lui ont confié mais
déjà justement restent nécessaires quant
au délai de réponse et la lenteur des
processus d'affectation
pourtant la prise en compte des
inégalités suivies par les jeunes au
bureau restent le parent pauvre de nos
politiques publiques selon les données
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale 10
millions de jeunes de moins de 20 ans
grandissent dans des communes de moins
de 25000 habitants
comme la montre le sociologue Nicolas
renailly l'enclavement à ses
conséquences réelles sur les
opportunités offertes aux jeunes bien
souvent ils doivent se restreindre aux
formations proposées sur les territoires
ou bien
partie d'autres raisons parfois
difficilement quantifiable explique les
difficultés d'accès aux formations
post-bac c'est notamment le cas de
l'autocensure le manque d'information
disponible les difficultés économiques
ainsi que l'ensemble des freins à la
mobilité divers en octobre 2018 le
gouvernement avait lancé une mission
Visante à mieux prendre en compte les
particularités de certains territoires
en particulier les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
et les territoires ruraux c'était une
bonne chose plusieurs conclusions
s'imposent d'une part les politiques
scolaires rurales ont tendance à être
parcellaires et mal articulé avec les
politiques d'aménagement
d'autre part les inégalités
territoriales se creusent si les zonage
scolaires prend seulement en compte les
difficultés sociales concentrées à la
même territoire il oublie de ce fait les
difficultés disperser la mobilité ou la
fracture numérique par exemple trop
souvent les inégalités scolaires de sont
appréhendées que sous l'angle des
inégalités sociales mais n'oublions pas
les inégalités territoriales sujets
auxquels nous sommes attachés dans cette
maison mes chers collègues c'est
notamment le cas avec la rubrique
activité et centre d'intérêt complétés
par les jeunes futurs étudiants pour
augmenter leur chance d'intégrer la
filière de leur choix
cette rubrique est source d'inégalité
face à la demande croissante et au
caractère non extensible dès le causes
universitaires certaines écoles sont en
effet tentées de sélectionner les
étudiants sur des critères dépassant le
sable de ces scolaire dès lors
deviennent parfois nécessaire des
séjours linguistiques à l'étranger un
service civique ou encore le BAFA autant
de facteurs censés permettre aux jeunes
de se démarquer des autres or les jeunes
des territoires ruraux ne disposent pas
des mêmes ressources que ceux des
grandes agglomérations ils sont trop
souvent démuni lorsque vient le moment
de compléter leur profil sur la
plateforme
l'accueil a et l'accès par un stage à
une activité extra-scolaire ou encore à
une association dans laquelle s'engager
bien évidemment plus
facile en difficile pardon en zone peu
dense là encore les origines
géographiques restent déterminantes dans
l'orientation poste bac et dans la
difficulté et la capacité à se projeter
dans l'avenir en octobre 2022 l'enquête
une jeunesse engagée sur les étudiants
de Sciences Po a été publiée pour 36%
d'entre eux ce sont les relations qui
comptent le plus dans la formation de
l'élite contre 20% en 2002 les diplômes
sont déterminants pour seulement 14%
d'entre eux contre 36% en 2002 cette
étude doit nous alerter l'avenir est
quelque chose qui se surmonte on ne le
subit pas on le fait disait Georges
bernados à l'auteur que j'affectionne
tant il s'est attaché à décrire les
charmes de ma région les hauts de France
nous devons dessiner une politique
éducative prenant en compte l'ensemble
des jeunes leur parcours et leur
territoire d'implantation il faut pour
cela compléter des dispositifs actuels
d'égalité des chances parcoursup dont
l'algorithme détermine le parcours de
notre jeunesse doit pouvoir y contribuer
les gènes ruraux demande tout simplement
à bénéficier des mêmes chances de
réussir que les autres à nous de montrer
à notre jeunesse rurale comme urbaine
que nous avons entendu cette demande et
que nous la prenons à bras le corps il
est crucial en effet que chaque jeune
Français d'où qu'il vienne bénéficie des
mêmes chances lors de son orientation
post-bac dès lors madame la ministre
j'aimais le souhait au nom du groupe Les
Indépendants que la fracture
territoriale soit davantage prise en
compte par la plateforme parcoursup afin
qu'elle contribue à la réduire je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur Jean-Pierre de Cole
d'abord merci merci d'évoquer ce soir
avec l'engagement que nous vous
connaissons cette question de la
fracture sociale et de l'égalité d'accès
aux services publics pour les jeunes et
en particulier vous l'avez dit pour les
jeunes des territoires ruraux alors une
petite précision que vous m'accorderez
non ce n'est pas un algorithme
parcoursup qui fait ou défait l'avenir
de la jeunesse
je l'ai dit précédemment c'est bien le
côté humain qui est présent dans cette
procédure mais je vous rejoins
complètement parcoursup comme les autres
dispositifs qui est porté par mon
ministère et celui de l'éducation
nationale doit être mobilisée pour
assurer l'égalité d'accès et de réussite
pour tous les jeunes parcoursup il
contribue croyez le bien d'abord en
permettant à tous quel que soit le lieu
habitations d'accéder à la même
information sur toutes les formations de
l'Hexagone je vous rappelle aussi que
nous donnons avec parcoursup une
visibilité sur le réseau des BTS ou
encore des ifs si dont on sait que leur
maillage fin permet de répondre aux
problématiques d'attractivité des
territoires ruraux pour lutter contre
cette autocensure nous avons promu les
cordées de la réussite en demandant
précisément à ce qu'elle puisse
concerner aussi les territoires ruraux
aujourd'hui c'est 26000 jeunes
collégiens au collège ruraux qui
participent à ses cordées et seront sans
doute mieux demain préparer au choix sur
parcoursup avec un accès favorisé nous
prendrons mieux en compte cet accès
décoré et des boursiers mais pour
répondre à votre problématique vous le
savez bien il faut dépasser
effectivement le seul cap de parcoursup
car les inégalités territoriales ne sont
pas créées uniquement parcoursup c'est
pour cela que ma prédécesseur a mis en
place avec le soutien des collectivités
territoriales c'est campus connectés qui
permettent d'associer études à distance
et soutien à la réussite de proximité il
y en a aujourd'hui 80 sur le territoire
et nous allons continuer à travailler
sur le maillage de territoire avec des
formations présentielles tellement
nécessaire à nos étudiants je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre et la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue Jacques
gros Perrin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je remercie le
groupe CRCE et Pierre rouzulia d'avoir
mis en place des bas en tout cas
parcoursup qui n'est-il pas celui de la
question de la sélection université ces
modalités ces acceptabilités c'est
stigmates en tout cas la hantise pour un
gouvernement d'une loi de vachebis en 86
qui est encore dans toutes les mémoires
des élus et de nous-mêmes un million
dans la rue 150000 pour la police et
pourtant les défis restaient les mêmes
je disais je disais déjà en 2018 lors du
débat sur la loi hors que les étudiants
étaient de plus en plus nombreux avec un
échec massif en licence et c'est ainsi
que les difficultés d'APB en 2017 on
précipité des choses et imposer qu'une
réforme de l'admission de l'enseignement
supérieur soit mené dans l'urgence suite
à un tirage au sort inacceptable
fallait-il pour autant comme je disais
j'étais affaibli avec l'eau du bain car
rappelez bien introduisait déjà à partir
de 2008 un portail de coordination des
admissions dans l'enseignement supérieur
ce qui faisait dire à l'époque à la Cour
des comptes qu'il fallait une véritable
simplification pour gérer les flux sans
être un système d'orientation ou ni un
instrument de sélection ce n'était pas
pour la Cour des comptes les signes du
défaillance intrinsèque de l'outil mais
en révélateur des choix ministériels en
matière d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur qui ne répondait pas à la
réalité de la situation est-ce que c'est
la changer madame la ministre ce sera ma
première question un travail avec les
universités les branches pôles et
l'écosys régionaux doivent être menées
avec les rectorats afin de réorienter
l'offre de formation il faut aussi
l'adapter aux besoins présents et futurs
de notre économie la CMP du 13 février
2018 au Sénat ou Gabriel Attal
rapporteur pour l'Assemblée nationale et
moi-même pour le Sénat comme rapporteur
et vous tous collègues présents qui
aviez déjà formulé de nombreux
inquiétudes reste d'actualité et je la
mesure mais notre sens des
responsabilités pour une CMP conclusive
à épaisé car 850 000 jeunes étaient en
attente de parcoursup avec une loi
programmulguée le 8 mars 2018 pour une
rentrée 6 mois plus tard et certains sur
ces bancs s'en souviennent je passe
simplement les initiateurs aujourd'hui
les problèmes restent les mêmes car la
massification de la formation post-bac
et la démocratisation soulève deux
difficultés le fonctionnement il s'agit
tout simplement des capacités d'accueil
des moyens avec une dépense pour
l'enseignement supérieur qui atteint
juste 1,5% de sa richesse la France est
très loin des 2% du PIB fixé par le
livre blanc et le deuxième point c'est
l'équité l'efficacité d'un système
l'inégalité d'accès et de réussite qui
est aujourd'hui largement renseignée
alors que le diplôme reste la clé
d'accès à l'emploi que sa valeur
performative augmente avec le niveau
d'études et que les grandes écoles
restent gagnantes dans ce contexte
général parcoursup reste symbole de nos
objectifs aussi bien que de nos limites
et parfois insuffisantes mais il a
permis néanmoins un meilleur effort
collectif d'orientation et une formation
plus lisible cela favorise à une
responsabilité accrue des étudiants sur
ce qui sera attendu 2 les critiques ont
été de nombreuses et puis d'origine
système trop concurrentiel lenteur
efficacité insuffisante absence de
transparence et pourtant le Conseil
constitutionnel a reconnu la
constitutionnalité du dispositif d'accès
à parcoursup 3 avril 2020 chaque
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
doit être en capacité de rencontre des
critères en fonction desquels sont
examinés les candidatures dans le cadre
de parcoursup cette décision à
stabiliser juridiquement parcoursup et
légitimier le travail des universités
sur ces bases de stabilisation il est
difficile d'imaginer la suppression de
la plateforme même si plusieurs
candidats lors des présidentielles
avaient proposé la suppression mais
quelle solution alternative sur ce débat
sur ces bases plusieurs questions
émergentes où en est-on aujourd'hui
quelle piste pour mieux gérer 2023 quel
objectif chiffré pour la prochaine
rentrée et prochaine phases de vœux quel
indicateur fiable sur l'efficacité du
système quelle piste d'évolution sur les
listes d'attentes et des lycéens qui se
retrouvent sans affectation comment
assurer enfin une place pour toute
étudiant autant de questions qui chez
nos jeux une vision négative ou déformée
de parcoursup avec un baromètre de
confiance qui montre une réelle
d'illusion qui ne permettrait pas un
accès équitable ou supérieur 36% restent
très intensifs insatisfaits des délais
de réponse des propositions d'admission
le fonctionnement même de la plateforme
qui impose un travail en amont difficile
pour beaucoup le processus de validation
qui peut conduire une forme
d'autocensure plus à l'extrême enfin
comment remédier à cet axe critique
quelle peut-être vos propositions madame
la ministre contre les inégalités
réelles si constatées lutter contre les
inégalités ressenties communiquer mieux
davantage parcours sup prend-il
suffisamment en compte ses
complémentarité c'est aussi toute la
question de la mobilité des jeunes un
nombre accru de lycéens quitte leur
région pour étudier des quotas ont été
mis en place imposés bien sûr notamment
pour les établissements la capitale
bilan chiffre perspective et conséquent
de cette mobilité ce sera le rôle et la
fonction de notre mission sous la
responsabilité de notre cher maxi
Brisson qui sera effectué avec
l'ensemble de tous les sénateurs ici
présents je vous remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jacques opéra alors un petit
peu en vrac à vos réponses mais quand
même quel progrès apporté parcoursup je
vais le redire aujourd'hui il y a plus
d'admission les évolutions et les
améliorations continuent sont réelles
même si et je le redis il doit y en
avoir encore pour moins de stress plus
d'accompagnement plus d'accès mais 93%
des lycéens ont au moins une proposition
aujourd'hui c'est les chiffres qui les
montrent et c'est une réalité des
candidats sont accompagnés tout au long
de procédure je voudrais rappeler qu'il
y a 11 campagnes téléphoniques qui
appellent en SMS ou au téléphone les
candidats un par un à partir d'un moment
donné au niveau de parcoursup le travail
des KS qu'on a salué que je salue et à
la fin effectivement 160 lycéens étaient
encore à la fin de la procédure mais
continue à être accompagné en fin de
procédure il en restait il n'y a pas
longtemps 33 sans proposition d'accès
nous n'arrêtons pas après les KS et puis
les rapports publics je rappelle aussi
pour avoir des chiffres pour avoir ces
critères de transparence en 2022 ça sera
11 732 rapports publics que l'on a reçu
aujourd'hui et que qui seront rendus
publics sur parcoursup et qui seront
utilisés dans la suite pour les
étudiants pour les orientations donc de
même pour la lutte contre les inégalités
5 points de plus pour les boursiers on
l'a vu de 20 à 25% de boursiers et
beaucoup plus de mobilité avec un
accompagnement de 500 euros pour les
boursiers pour avoir de la mobilité et
je le redis l'idée de l'accès c'est
l'idée de l'accès en premier cycle en
proximité mais aussi l'idée d'accès de
ne pas interdire à un étudiant d'accéder
partout en France à la formation qu'il
souhaite et dont il peut avoir accès je
voudrais vous redire un point avant de
terminer vous parlez beaucoup tous de
l'échec massif en licence c'est une
réalité on le sait mais
mais on est bon on est mauvais c'est
toujours par rapport à quelque chose et
je voudrais vous inciter à regarder le
dernier rapport de l'OCDE qui me permet
de nous comparer par rapport aux
formations à l'Europe à ses échecs en
premier cycle à ce 2% de PIB et comment
la France et son enseignement supérieur
par rapport au PIB des pays permet de se
positionner aujourd'hui oui il y a des
progrès à faire mais vous verrez que
quand même même par rapport aux
établissements européens nous tenons
notre place merci beaucoup
merci
merci madame la ministre et pour
terminer ces interventions
la parole à notre collègue Stéphane
Piednoir le groupe les républicains
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues pour mettre en
perspective nos débats du jour et pour
conclure permettrait de faire un peu
d'historique comme chacun sait le
baccalauréat est à la fois le premier
diplôme de l'enseignement supérieur mais
également le sésame pour accéder à ce
niveau chaque année ainsi plus de 600
000 jeunes bacheliers aspire à une
poursuite d'études qui correspondent à
leurs ambitions et si possible alors
capacité tout le monde peut comprendre
que cette grosse machine nécessite un
minimum d'organisations pour être
efficace pour relativiser les griefs qui
peuvent être légitimes sur le système
actuel je voudrais évoquer un temps que
les moins de 40 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître beaucoup d'entre nous ont
connu une procédure d'affectation avant
l'heure du numérique qui consistait pour
les filières dites sélectives à envoyer
son dossier par la poste à
l'établissement accueillant la formation
de son vœu préférentiel puis en cas de
réponse négative
toujours par courrier répéter la
procédure pour chacun des voeux suivants
rigoureusement pierre cela s'appelle un
algorithme et vous conviendrez qu'il
était pas optimale y compris sur le fond
puisque aucune justification du refus
n'était exigible depuis la mastification
de l'accès au baccalauréat la croissance
quasi ininterrompue du taux de réussite
et la multiplication des cursus post-bac
on considérablement alourdé la tâche de
ceux qui sont chargés d'examiner les
dossiers et de faire en toute conscience
professionnelle les choix d'affectation
un système entièrement manuel n'était
plus tenable et nous avons vu
l'apparition de l'admission post-bac qui
a su répondre globalement quoi qu'on en
dise à cette situation
la difficulté porte sur le problème
théorique dit des mariages stables
consistant à trouver étant donné n homme
et n femme et leur liste de préférence
une façon stable de les mettre en couple
c'est l'algorithme de guerre et chapelet
qui ont 62 parvient à résoudre ce
problème qui servira pour élaborer la
plateforme admission post-bac mais il y
a un billet majeur la fonction de
préférence qui privilégie un groupe
plutôt que l'autre le parti pris pour
admission post-bac comme pour parcoursup
d'ailleurs qui reprend les mêmes
caractéristiques techniques c'est de
donner priorité aux préférences de
l'établissement
qu'est-ce qui nécessitait une refonte de
cette procédure essentiellement la
hiérarchisation des voeux et leur grand
nombre contenus de la multiplicité des
combinaisons possibles les grandes
nouveautés de parcoursup instituées avec
la loi orientation et réussite des
étudiants en 2018 sont l'extension de la
procédure aux universités et à plus de
15000 formations ainsi que la
publication datant du pour mieux
informer chaque candidat et le diriger
vers les choix les plus pertinents mais
beaucoup restent encore à faire en
termes d'orientation et c'est sur ce
point que j'aimerais insister
comme l'avait pointé la Cour des comptes
en 2020 l'orientation des élèves est
identifiée comme une priorité des
pouvoirs publics mais la mise en oeuvre
de cette politique rencontre des
obstacles majeurs la stratégie
d'orientation dans le supérieur commence
sans doute plutôt aujourd'hui qu'il y a
plusieurs années et le fait même
d'évoquer une stratégie laisse entrevoir
toutes les difficultés auquel peuvent
être confrontées certains jeunes et
leurs familles les inégalités sociales
se creusent donc au niveau Bac -3
puisque les milieux les moins favorisés
se reposent quasi intégralement sur les
équipes éducatives pour rendre pour
prendre en charge l'orientation de leurs
enfants pour répondre à ça la Cour des
comptes et l'inspection générale de
l'éducation pointe un besoin croissant
en matière d'information et de
professionnalisation des différents
acteurs du processus d'orientation cela
vaut pour les établissements scolaires
mais également pour les formations de
l'enseignement supérieur dans leur
processus de recrutement nous espérons
madame la minisque des élections des
actions concrètes seront entreprises
dans ce domaine pour permettre ça
parcoursup d'atteindre l'un de ses
objectifs essentiel mis en avant en 2018
[Applaudissements]
merci
la parole à madame la ministre vous
pouvez répondre à Monsieur Piednoir mais
vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez
enchaîner sur la réponse globale
puisque ensuite de toute façon je vous
repasserai la parole pour faire la
conclusion globale du débat donc vous
pouvez enchaîner les deux si vous le
souhaitez merci monsieur le Président je
pense que je vais accepter parce que mes
réponses dans la bilan global répondra
probablement enfin certainement à
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir donc si
vous si vous le permettez je peux vous
répondre en même temps sur l'ensemble
des réponses ce qui permettra d'avoir
une vision en plus globale
je viens
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président et Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs alors permettez-moi tout
d'abord vraiment de vous remercier de
remercier pour ce débat pour la qualité
de vos interventions ce soir et tous les
points pertinents bien évidemment et
identifiez que vous avez soulevé je l'ai
dit parcoursup n'est qu'une plateforme
mais une plateforme qui doit être au
service des futurs étudiants sur cette
plateforme les formations ont une
responsabilité première bien évidemment
au fond ce qu'il faut rappeler au moment
de clore ce débat c'est que la procédure
parcoursup assure un échange entre les
lycéens et entre les enseignants des
formations post-bac avec l'aide et ses
fondamentales des professeurs principaux
qui sont au plus près des lycéens
la loi du 8 mars 2018 l'a organisé
autour de plusieurs ambitions qui sont
et je n'en doute pas partager sur tous
les bancs de cette hémicycle l'ambition
de renforcer l'accompagnement à
l'orientation au lycée pour en faire un
tremplin vers cet enseignement du
supérieur l'ambition de mettre fin aux
inscriptions par ordre d'arrivée comme
vous l'avez dit dans la nuit ou par
tirage au sort en fixant des règles
transparentes j'y reviendrai connu de
tous
l'ambition aussi d'améliorer la réussite
de tous les étudiants
l'ambition enfin de renforcer la
démocratisation de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur
sur chacun de ces points que deux
chemins parcourus quand même depuis cinq
ans au lycée l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur est devenu un enjeu majeur qui
mobilise toutes les équipes éducatives
avec le souci de sécuriser mais aussi
d'accompagner le parcours des lycéens en
2022 plus de bacheliers ont eu de
propositions d'admission et ils les ont
eu beaucoup plus vite comme le montre
les enquêtes et les différents chiffres
grâce au travail des rectorats je
voudrais les saluer le travail de tous
nos collègues rectorat enseignants du
secondaire et du supérieur le nombre de
lycéens sans solution à la fin de la
procédure a été considérablement réduit
au cours des années ils étaient comme je
l'ai déjà dit 160 en septembre 2022
et nous avons continué à les encadrer à
les suivre pour réduire encore parce que
chaque étudiant est important pour tous
en 2023 en intégrant dans le dossier
parcoursup les notes des épreuves
finales des enseignements de spécialités
nous redonnerons toutes sa légitimité au
baccalauréat nous renforcerons
l'objectivité de l'analyse des
candidatures mais aussi l'articulation
-3 + 3 que parcoursup a fait progresser
comme jamais auparavant la transparence
vous l'avez tous rappelé est un objectif
majeur au service de l'orientation des
lycéens nous avons encore des progrès à
faire mais jamais autant de données
n'ont été rendues publiques par mon
ministère les règles de parcoursup sont
simples et publiques l'obligation faite
aux formations de rendre compte de leurs
critères et de leur choix est effective
pour cette session 2022 11 732 rapports
ont été remplis par les chefs
d'établissement et vous les rendront
tous accessibles le tirage au sort c'est
terminé depuis cinq ans et
l'automaticité que la CNIL avait
reproché à APB est fini ce sont
d'affirmer qu'avec parcoursup la
sélection se serait accrue à
l'université oui les règles d'admission
ont évolué oui l'examen des dossiers et
la règle parce que cela sert la
méritocratie mais aussi la réussite de
nos étudiants infinés cette réussite
étudiante est la progressé depuis
parcoursup d'au moins 5 points et cela
sans tenir compte des résultats sans
doute exceptionnels de l'année 2020 la
tendance est claire et la
personnalisation des parcours doit
devenir et devient une réalité dans les
universités la démocratisation enfin a
également progressé
le comité éthique et scientifique de
parcoursup c'est plus 5 points de
lycéens boursier admis c'est plus de
mobilité étudiante c'est un accès
renforcé des bacheliers professionnels
et technologiques dans les filières
professionnalisante et bien sûr cette
dynamique d'amélioration doit se
poursuivre c'est mon engagement celui du
président de la République qui a pris
l'engagement je cite de rendre
parcoursup plus prévisible en donnant
des résultats précis des années
précédentes et en accompagnant mieux les
familles avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous souhaitons prendre en
compte le ressenti des lycéens et malgré
une appréciation positive globale sur
l'expérience parcoursup il manifeste
effectivement encore des attentes en
termes de réduction du stress de
transparence de la procédure c'est
pourquoi nous conduirons des
améliorations qui s'articuleront autour
de quatre axes stratégiques qui seront
alimentés par plusieurs éléments de
notre discussion de ce soir tout d'abord
renforcer l'accompagnement à
l'orientation pour aider les lycéens et
leur famille à faire des choix et
favoriser la réussite des étudiants
ensuite rendre l'examen des candidatures
plus transparents et les résultats
d'admission sur parcoursup plus
prévisible en troisième axe améliorer
l'efficacité de la face principale pour
réduire la tente des candidats et le
stress induit en quatrième axe enfin
prolongé le continuum de réussite du
lycée vers l'enseignement supérieur pour
favoriser cette réussite étudiante mais
aussi l'insertion professionnelle après
le cycle licence ces progrès nous les
engagerons en lien avec les acteurs de
l'enseignement supérieur car rien ne
pourra se faire sans sel et ce qui
donnent de leur temps pour les journées
portes ouvertes pour l'examen des
candidatures sur parcoursup et dont je
sais pour avoir été l'une d'entre eux
qu'ils n'ont qu'un seul but accueillir
les futurs étudiants les former et les
faire réussir dans leurs études et tout
au long de leurs études
c'est normal que dans une période de
choix nous devons tout faire pour que
ces choix se fassent dans la sérénité et
ces processus sont en train d'être
étudiés avec le ministre dans
l'enseignement supérieur pour être mis
en oeuvre dès cette année et j'espère
pouvoir venir vous les présenter dans le
détail et l'année prochaine lors d'un
bilan avec un vrai une vraie
amélioration de ce système parcoursup
dont les chiffres disent déjà beaucoup
et dans le bilan l'année prochaine sera
encore meilleur je vous remercie
merci merci madame la ministre et pour
conclure le débat je vais passer la
parole à Pierre ouzullias pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen avant de
vous passer la parole chers collègues je
voudrais rappeler à tous mes tous les
collègues qui ont participé à ce débat
que quand la ministre utilise son droit
de réponse à chaque intervenant vous
avez la possibilité d'une réplique d'une
minute personne ne l'a utilisé ce soir
mais c'est parce que nous tous les
ministres ne répondent pas
systématiquement à la question donc on a
du mal à ce que les règles
s'approprier toutes les règles mais je
le rappelle parce que ça peut servir
pour d'autres débats contre la ministre
répond vous pouvez aussi utiliser une
réplique d'une minute à la suite de sa
réponse
pour conclure le débat
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
voudrais très sincèrement vous remercier
par pour la qualité de vos interventions
qui étaient très complémentaires je
pense que Madame la mitrise la ministre
vous allez en conclure que nous étions
organisés au sein de la commission de la
culture pour se répartir les sujets
c'est même pas la peine parce que nous
sommes en cohérence sur sur beaucoup de
sujets comme vous pouvez le constater je
voudrais aussi très sincèrement vous
remercier pour vos réponses toujours
extrêmement
argumentés et vous avez parfaitement
illustré ce qui est la
disputatio universitaire un échange
rationnel sur sur des bases qui sont
connaît tout le monde et puis je
voudrais remercier France université qui
nous ont envoyé des notes extrêmement
utiles qu'on nourrit aussi nos nos
discussions
le point important pour commencer sur
les
dessus et je vais essayer de présenter
la plus honnête possible un certain
nombre des points sur lesquels nous
sommes d'accord chers collègues le
premier point c'est vous avez rappelé
ici avec force mais c'est pas la
première fois votre souci d'illustrer
une université républicaine c'est un
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
fondamental et nous pensons qu'à
l'échelle internationale le modèle
français de l'école républicaine de
l'université républicaine est un modèle
d'avenir en dehors d'autres modèles du
modèle anglo-saxon par exemple qui est
fondé sur d'autres d'autres principes
j'ajouterai puisque il a été question à
plusieurs reprises d'égalité des chances
que le service public repose sur
l'égalité des droits ce qui est pas tout
à fait la même chose et ça a une valeur
beaucoup plus importante dans tous mes
de Ba finalement il plusieurs questions
extrêmement importantes qui sont qui
sont revenus et qui et qui n'ont jamais
été réellement posées notre société
c'est-à-dire combien la France veut-elle
d'étudiants aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que
la nation est prête aujourd'hui
a financer pour son université qui sont
de fond qu'est-ce que nous voulons et je
pense que ça serait nettement plus
intéressant de commencer par par ce
débat là on le voit bien ces jours
derniers que la question des
mathématiques a été tout à fait
essentielle et hier je crois le PDG du
CNRS a lancé un cri d'alarme en disant
que il manquait de mathématiciens pour
que la France pour que le CNRS continue
à être à son niveau là je pense qu'il
nous faut
nous poser ces questions pas filaire par
filière mais par grande masse de
discipline est-ce qu'on a encore besoin
d'archéologues ce qu'on a encore besoin
d'historien
c'est ce jeu je crois que c'est tout à
fait important de placer le débat à ce
niveau là parce que ensuite on peut
réfléchir sur les modes de recrutement
les procédures de recrutement mais au
moins il y a une ligne directrice un
horizon d'attente générale qui est
défini par le politique et qui nous
permet de de discuter tout le monde a
insisté sur la nécessité de retravailler
sur le continent entre le lycée et la
licence c'est absolument fondamental je
vois à mon petit niveau que les
enseignants de l'université
connaissaient le bac dans son ancienne
formule ici j'ai dans les commissions
aujourd'hui ils sont dans l'incapacité
très souvent de comprendre ce qui se
passe réellement au lycée et dans le bac
donc il faut absolument rapprocher les
uns des autres et je crois qu'il y a
d'abord un travail de formation
désenseignant à faire sur ce qui est
l'université pour les uns et ce qui le
lycée pour pour les autres je vais je
vais très vite sur les algorithmes
locaux comme tout le monde est déçu que
j'en ai pas parlé
ce que ce que tout le monde souhaite
madame la mise mais je crois que vous
êtes d'accord c'est que il y ait une
information sur les méthodes utilisées
par par les jurys pour trier
préalablement dans des fichiers Excel
généralement c'est ça les dossiers des
étudiants aujourd'hui c'est donner ne
sont pas disponibles il faut qu'elles
soient ex hantée et je crois que c'est
très important que dans les rapports
qu'on a consulté ce que nous envoyait
France France université aujourd'hui ces
critères ne sont pas précisés l'étudiant
le cand pardon a besoin de savoir
qu'est-ce que vaut ma note de maths
qu'est-ce que vous etc il y a une
demande très forte que que je relai ici
sur le caractère
qui doit être rendue le plus possible
anonyme du lycée d'origine on a le
sentiment les candidats ont le sentiment
qui sont aujourd'hui classés en fonction
de leur lycée des régimes d'origine bien
évidemment c'est un biais c'est quelque
chose qui est tout à fait contraire à
l'esprit réplicain de l'université je
vais m'arrêter là ce que j'ai déjà
dépassé mon temps merci monsieur le
président
merci chers collègues je vous remercie
tous pour ce débat et Madame la Ministre
pour ces réponses mes chers collègues je
vais lever la séance la prochaine séance
aura lieu le mardi 15 novembre à 14h30
pour les explications de votre dégroupe
puis le scrutin public solennel sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 la séance est
levée
[Musique]